I'm turning my attention back to
the El Salvador president actually after
we did the segment on him yesterday I
noticed that President bouquet in El
Salvador tweeted out the bit from this
show and and quoted the segment
and
then I went to the president's Twitter
page I said oh that's kind of cool he
tweeted out the segment and then I saw
he had another video and this is kind of
the answer to the propaganda video of
the MS-13 gangsters that he put out you
know president bouquet has arrested
thousands and thousands of these
gangsters I think there's 65 000 of them
now locked up these guys look like demon
bugs they've got weird green face
tattoos and he's humiliating them and
he's sent the Army out to deal with the
crime problem
and reduce the murder rate by 58 well
now here's the other side of that not
just the Doom and Gloom and fire and
brimstone we're gonna get you bad guys
here's
the hopeful message for the rest of the
country I will translate by reading the
text on the screen because my Spanish is
no good
president bouquet standing out
talking to his troops in a field for
eight months we've been fighting this
war against the gangs and thank God
we're winning
this is a very surprising victory that
is nearly within our grass let it be
clear that the glory is for God
and it is God's glory
we humans are lucky
to be instruments of God all of us
to bring peace Liberty and happiness
to the Salvadoran people these values
were probably not strong in this land
and were strong in other languages and
that's why those lands grew and became
they are losing those values
previously were degraded in our country
are now the most important ones
just take a look at yourself
how could a nation not rise up with
values such as these How could a nation
not rise up when it puts God first and
then puts in the hard work and effort
with these kinds of values
beautiful
political science students will be
studying this speech history students
will be studying this speech years from
now
this is beautiful
simple and true
the president of El Salvador
sounds like an American founding father
in that speech
more so he sounds like
Governor Bradford Governor Winthrop were
some of the very earliest Americans who
helped to build our country
they kept it very simple
it's just like the policy what's the
policy you want to fight crime lock up
the criminals
you want to build a great nation put God
first everything else will follow seek
ye first the kingdom of heaven all the
other Goods will follow after that
president bukele he says
in our country these values had been
degraded other nations had those values
that's why those other nations became
great and now those other nations are
turning away from those values who's he
talking about he's talking about us
and he's showing you something beautiful
that happens throughout history
and that you see
certainly in the history of Salvation
certainly you see this throughout the
Bible
that
very often it can be small Mighty groups
small Underdog groups
who put on the armor of God
who can astound
and frankly embarrass
the supposedly far greater Nations
which have profited
profited from God's grace and then
turned their backs on him go on done
something else doesn't turn out well for
those countries doesn't turn out well
for those Empires
he says that line
How could a nation with these values not
rise up not become great
and not it's very very simple I'm not
saying that it's easy but it's simple
president buchelli's speech here could
have been given
not just by the founding fathers or the
early Colonial Americans could have been
given by any great leader in our
civilization going back to Antiquity all
the way up until about 20 years ago
now we don't hear these speeches very
often
but it's pretty simple stuff folks
these big political problems
that our opponents want to pretend are
so complicated oh well you know gender
and sex it's so it's not complicated men
or men and women are women well you know
the issue of reproductive freedom and no
it's not don't kill babies it's really
simple well the issue of immigration is
so complicated Ronald Reagan said
illegal immigration is not complicated
it's illegal stop it
crime is not complicated lock up the
criminals build more prisons lock them
up punish them harder you'll get less
crime
how do we have a great country look
toward God look to the source and Summit
of goodness himself being himself you'll
have a good country you look away from
God you're going to have a bad country
it's very very simple
so the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles can wlas a check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
ha